[Music]
a man who was traveling on a
manhattan-bound n train
opened two canisters that dispensed
smoke throughout the subway car
he then shot multiple passengers as the
train pulled into the 36th street
station in sunset park
10 people were injured by gunfire and an
additional 13 were either uh injured as
the they rushed to get out of the train
station or they suffered smoke
inhalation
when i came out i saw a cloud of smoke
and i saw people in chaos laying on the
floor three people on the floor and they
also it automatically told me to run so
i ran out and i just got out the train
station because i didn't know what was
going on
we're conducting a highly coordinated
investigation that includes nypd
detectives
the fbi nypd joint terrorism task force
and the atf
who have been instrumental in tracing
the firearm and ballistics the suspect
is a dark-skinned male and was wearing a
neon orange vest and a gray-colored
sweatshirt we do have a person of
interest in this investigation
i'm a little shocked and i'm hoping that
it gets better because i'm noticing it's
happening all over
new york city
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you